in much of western europe and america
seasonings mean salt and pepper
they're so strong appearing that we even
use them to describe people
think of george clooney and his
trademark salt and pepper hair
but where did they come from and why do
they form such ubiquitous pairing
salt is essential for life and it's been
used since prehistoric times either
scraped from saltwater deposits
harvested from salty lakes or mined from
underground
it's one of the earliest food industries
and one of the most important
commodities in the world
it makes food taste better but it's also
vital for preservation whether of meat
or vegetables
methods for producing and controlling it
were developed by all the classic
civilizations most notably the romans
who left their mark on modern day
language with their word for salt
sal roman soldiers received their salary
money to buy salt
and salads were vegetables and greens
seasoned with salt
in the medieval period salt was
expensive and frequently controlled by
the state
huge ornate vessels for the table were
made out of gold and silver dominating
dinner tables and indicating very
clearly who was of high status
sitting below the salt i.e not on the
highest table well
clearly you weren't exactly exalted
having salt on the table was as much of
a show as practicality but dishes were
seasoned in the kitchen
but adding salt to one's meat the tip of
the knife was common practice
and the uncertain noble could buy
written advice on exactly how salt
etiquette worked along with the even
thornier question of how to carve
but how did peppa come to join it it was
one among a wide range of spices
available to the medieval cook and it
was expensive
in the 1430s one pound of peppercorns
cost as much as a pig
in the late 15th century the portuguese
took control of malabar in east india
and started cultivating black pepper on
a large scale
prices fell in line with oversupply and
pepper became more readily available
by the 16th century the phrase
peppercorn rent was in use to mean a
nominal sum
the real boost though came with a change
in culinary fashion to favor the french
they loved black pepper and their chefs
were busy tidying and simplifying
medieval cuisine
delineating more firmly sweet from
savory and codifying which ingredients
worked with which
salt was obviously savory pepper tended
that way
and so the fashionable french style
dishes of the next century used both
together and with fewer and fewer other
spices
by the victorian age salt and pepper
were coming together as standard
seasonings
however other forms of pepper vine with
black and cayenne also appeared
frequently in cookery books
salt was still on the table now in small
salt cellars no longer just for the
privileged few
in 1911 the morton salt company of
chicago patented an easy flow salt
and salt shakers could finally take off
during the 20th century pepper shakers
joined them
then as package holidays introduced
brits to freshly ground pepper at the
table
peppermill has replaced the shakers few
it's not a ubiquitous combination
everywhere though other cultures might
still have the salt but replace the
black pepper with chili
and let us not forget the pickles the
sambals the vinegars the fish sauces and
the salsas
can i make room on my table and have
them all